this video is sponsored by nordvpn Green
skyscrapers are an incredibly stupid
idea and are nothing but pointless
expensive green washing these idiotic
plant scrapers as they call them are the
ultimate symbol of pretending to be
environmentally friendly while doing
absolutely nothing to reduce your carbon
footprint they are a way to divert money
away from meaningful projects that would
actually help the environment recently
my senses were assed by this Forest City
project in Lucho China which then sent
me down a rabbit hole of buildings with
plants on them so what is the issue with
Forest cities and green skyscrapers the
guardian called them a radical plan to
save China from air pollution and here
in lies the first problem this is not a
radical plan but the ultimate clinging
to the status schol because news flash
sticking trees on the buildings of your
badly designed City doesn't fix things
magically the architect can talk as much
as they want about being an example to
the world but man what kind of example
is it really in this article the archite
is talking about two proposed Green
highrises in the Chinese city of nuning
and I'm just like dude have you seen
ning for those of you who haven't
[Music]
yet did they get Dubai to plan their
City this isn't even a city it's just a
jumble of copypaste highrises between
urban freeways actually this is a
perfect parallel to Dubai two
dictatorships collaborating with real
estate Giants to put up massive
unsustainable conrete jungles which is a
way to keep their cronies and political
allies on payroll and someone looks at
this the chaotic product of a
dictatorships collaboration with real
estate Capital divided by 12 laye Urban
freeways and says what if the buildings
had plants on them so we do see the
problem putting up green skyscrapers in
this environment does not address the
massive underlying systemic issues
plaguing the city and the country that
produced it even on renders of the
nuning vertical Forest the buildings are
on the corner of two 16 Lane Urban
freeways it's like that Urban Gondola
fever dream might I looked at earlier
where they wanted to put up these things
because there is no space but on their
own renders they have two five Lane
roads intersecting directly below
there's more than enough space just
convert two car Lanes into public
transit Lanes but since we live in the
world of automobile realism no one dares
to touch the car that would be too
radical of a plan one could say now
picture yourself sitting at your desk in
your green skyscraper apartment half the
plants have died there is a rat
infestation on all 60 floors because
people are throwing out their left doors
on the plants there's a hawk outside
your window tearing apart a pigeon and
state actors are listening in personally
on your chats well now thanks to nordvpn
you can keep dictators out of your
private life it can't do anything about
the rats or the hog nordvpn's virtual
private Network feature keeps you
Anonymous on the Internet by hiding your
physical location and encrypting your
personal data available both for Android
iOS and PC nordvpn is the number one VPN
provider on the market of course that
Flagship feature is the elimination of
region blocks want to check out that
Netflix show to block out the sounds of
the pigeon being torn apart as rats fall
from the upper floors oops should have
moved to the right country except boom
nordvpn to the rescue nordvpn is also
super useful if you travel a lot and
connect often to public Wi-Fi networks
if access is limited by time or data now
you can pretend to be someone else and
enjoy those limits one more time nordvpn
also has a new feature called meshnet
included for free in the subscription
meshnet is a safe and secure virtual
private Network linking multiple devices
where you can share files work on joint
projects or even do secure remote access
and if you want to have a land party but
one of your friends can't come down to
your place because their door is blocked
by rats you can still play through land
via meshnet without having to go through
public Game servers to get nordvpn's
2-year plan plus 4 months free use my
link nordvpn.com Edam something which
you will also find in the description
subscribing is risk-free since you also
get a 30-day money back guarantee big
thanks to Lord VPN for sponsoring
today's video so about those Forest
studies What If instead of trying to fix
air pollution with them we fix the
source of that pollution in most cities
a the major cause of air pollution is
transportation aside from industry and
power generation so how about we first
try to reduce the core dependency of
cities but that doesn't work I'm afraid
that would be too much of a radical plan
and we can't have those it's like buying
some high-tech automatic cleaning robot
to clean your poop off the living room
floor every day well could this not be
fixed by you just not on the
living room floor but bro using the
toilet is such a hassle bro you have to
like go there open the lid sit down then
you have to flush why use the toilet
when there is Cutting Edge technology
that can scrape your poop off the living
room floor even on this render of the
proposed Lucho Forest City there is a
six lay Urban freeway right in front of
it and I get that the city has control
over that part not the architect but
nonetheless no one should try to sell
this whole thing to us as some major Eco
Revolution to be fair the architect does
mention that the Project's environmental
contribution is minuscule but then why
even bother instead of buildings with
plants on them how about more bike Lanes
more public transit and less cars for
starters we can also talk about China
energy mix which is still 56% goal with
them continuing to invest in it so you
know the green Tower gets built and then
the new environmentally conscious
tenants turn on their toasters in the
morning so a Coal Power Plant spews out
as much CO2 as the entire green facade
captures in a day another issue is with
equal access to Green spaces a green
skyscraper is basically a worst version
of a residential building with a private
park and so who will live in these
buildings a bunch of regular people no
these buildings are for the effluent
upper middle class there is nothing
fundamentally wrong with putting up an
upper scale building for people who can
afford to live there but if you put the
greenery on those buildings instead of
Greening public spaces you're locking
access to Greenery behind a massive pay
wall so if you're not affluent upper
middle class or above you get to
continue living in the gray Concrete
Jungle while those who can afford it get
to live in this Sleek Eco future there
are also issues with how such buildings
are built and maintained you have to
lift all the trees and the bushes up
with a crane okay that's doable but what
happens if a tree dies on the 60th floor
and needs to be replaced do you bring
out another crane to lift up the new
tree or do you plant a smaller one one
and wait for it to grow I guess you
could do the second and what happens if
there are high winds up there and a tree
breaks falls down and kills someone on
the sidewalk if a tree grows big and
heavy enough and then tips over it could
take part of the facade with it too what
if the building settles and cracks form
on the tops the trees are placed in if
Roots get into those they can compromise
the building's structure so now aside
from water leaks and structural cracks
you also need to check for root
intrusions in your skyscraper also how
will you maintain the greenery to always
be in a safe optimal condition do you
train every tenant to become a gardener
on the side what if they don't want to
mess with gardening will management have
a specific Landscaping Company show up
and care for each plant platform
separately look I have done gardening
before and it can be a ton of work even
with simple plants you need to replant
them water them prune them check for
infestations and sicknesses fertilize
them now imagine you have to care for a
big hunking Garden on the side of a
skyscraper so the landscapers have to
repel Down the Walls with all their
gardening gear meaning you either need
to train landscapers to be industrial
climbers or you need to give industrial
climbers Landscaping lessons also how do
you water the facade is there a built-in
watering system I suppose there would
have to be we need to nail the
requirements of each plant constantly so
they don't get sick and brittle because
that might become a hazard imagine a
tree getting infected and starting to
rot on the inside which no one notices
so the tree becomes weaker and then gets
snapped by a strong wind what if it
falls down and hits and kills someone
below this risk would mean that during
storms or windy weather you would need
to close streets under plant scrapers or
construct a protective Arch or mesh up
the sidewalks all right but what if the
plants are supposed to be maintained
From the Inside by regular gardeners who
don't need to be industrial climbers how
do they schedule with every single
tenant a specific time and date where a
bunch of gardeners come over stomp
through your apartment once every two
weeks so they can through in some
Bush under your window what if
the tenant isn't home for two months and
can't let in the gardeners so the plants
at their apartment become dangerous and
overgrown or would the gardeners have
some utility access to each plant
platform without having to get inside
Apartments if that's the case I hope
you're ready for some gardening themed
burglaries jez I'm starting to feel like
gardening might not be the easiest and
most efficient when done vertically
along the sides of a skyscraper and just
hang on let's take this building as an
example how many trees does this thing
have 46 on The Wider side 14 on the
narrower side and we see nine trees on
the top so let's say there are 25 there
now this building is of course
three-dimensional so it has two extra
sides we cannot see which would mean an
additional 60 trees but in this case
let's stick to what we can directly see
with our own eyes so this green highrise
Sports an amazing 85 trees in total
proximately all right now hear me out
what if what if we planted those trees
on the ground look right next to
it there is a three-lane road what if we
narrowed it down to a two-lane road and
set up a row of trees between it and the
tram line so here we can fit 20 trees uh
we can put 10 more behind that building
another 20 fits in front of this
building in fact we can put 20 more
there in a double row a triple even if
the square is about this wide then a
third row of 20 trees would fit so it
would be behind this building kind of
like this so we have successfully found
space for 90 trees on the ground that's
five more than what our green high-rise
has and they're easy to maintain they
give shade to passers by and aren't
threatening to crush someone to death
when they tip over at least not nearly
as much as if they tipped over from the
30th floor not to mention trees on the
ground can grow much bigger and you
don't have to worry about the roots
compromising the building structure so
there we go with a little creativity we
have managed to out green a green
high-rise building it wasn't even
difficult because green skyscrapers and
high-rises or a bull nons solution to
Serious systemic problems the only
reason people like them is because they
look good at renders and they have an
environmentalist Vibe it's the
architectural equivalent of trying to
save the planet by buying the apples
with the organic sticker on them instead
of the regular ones but if you want
Greenery on a building nonetheless do I
have an idea for you a portable muder
scalable solution called potted plants
on your balcony otherwise before trying
to put trees on skyscrapers let's see if
we can put some on the ground first
instead of traffic lanes and parked cars
let's also put in more bike lanes and
public transit so less people will drive
so the air quality will improve not just
for the select few who can afford an
apartment in a plant scraper but for
everyone living in the city thank you
for watching and as always we won't be
fixing systemic issues with fleshy
renders and green washing if you like my
content please consider supporting me on
patreon or become a channel member here
on YouTube which is essentially the same
and I'll be seeing you next
time